so we decided we weren't happy swapping
and now we're going to let jacob beat
mallgate yeah and then we may be out of
time and this is this is how we're
ending it we are stubborn
i just went to the bathroom welcome back
how was it john during this jacob's
taking a 15-minute [ __ ] i woke the dog
i think i shared it
what do you think you smell it
you're right you're all right yeah i'm
joked
guys this is a joke
i'm also getting very tired
it takes a lot out of you maybe you
think the break will help i think so
yeah
ow
yeah let's go good
yeah
[ __ ] there's no way i should have gotten
hit or i should have dodged that
margaret you're doing good stuff curse
you
you'll make me fell over
we have been playing for
five hours five and a half hours correct
after waiting all day
yes
did you like how i text you like two
thirty in the morning
i too was thinking like what is the
appropriate amount of times i could text
the lana asking
i i felt like i was here
because i kept just refreshing my emails
yes show me your front market
oh target
they said show me your front market oh
i mean there's enough going on there
that it could be a market you could
get some fabrics in that
there's a lot of fabrics going on
i can't wait until we kill moga and it
turns out that there's a transformation
yeah phase two yeah yeah but not like
it's phase three really
getting bad wait until you see oh damn
it tapes
it takes out like holy minigun yeah
that's what isian does at the end of
sakura yeah
you're fighting him he's like cool
samurai boss and then he pulls out a
[ __ ] machine gun
come on
owl 2 was crazy i think that was my
hardest one
i
like to me that it was
not designed for the game
it is very difficult as soon as i
started using the flame umbrella that
changed everything yeah maybe it was
designed specifically for you to use all
of your tools
well all of them you can you know carry
and yeah everything like that but
dean of hatred
did not seem to be that bad
hammer smash
no jacob you're doing terribly
what's up jacob
thank you john keeping me humbled
oh
i know i know i know about the wolves
they distract him let me get some
swinging
but also i get so uncertain about the
what he's facing yeah
your damn source to poke there just to
poke
i love it
come on
come on
oh okay took a little chip there
[ __ ]
yeah
didn't work
it just doesn't let you use your seat
here
i'm gonna drink my flask
oh
it was for me yeah you're right
oh
jacob oh [ __ ]
the wolves get him get him get him
i got cocky at the end okay
oh
okay that would have been yourself
that would have been funny
i mean they did yeah
[ __ ] okay now i'm all amped
i've been walking on that's awesome yeah
good job wolves
oh you're trying to lock on feature eh
oh [ __ ] he spun around
oh knocking over trees
one time [ __ ] dragonite armor
did his jump up slam attack but then he
did like a 270.
like i was behind him
[ __ ] [ __ ] no i was to the right of
him and he spun left
almost all the way around and then
got me
i can see it
[Music]
it seems like they've maybe compensated
for that because that's what happened to
the knights
night guard or whatever yeah
and he just teleported back up
[ __ ] he always jumps away
invisible or something
three hits that's interesting i guess i
didn't realize he does that same jump
slam before the x yes
just without the hammer yeah
here we go
there he is
we'd love to see it
let's get the molds in now yeah
just get him in there get him in the
rink
he does alternate though
get up
all right wolves have been uh
annihilated very quickly
oh
it's getting a little uh greedy there
but you're doing [ __ ]
that's how you play destiny
no never
i'm just trying to bait that sword out
like i like to think he has a limited
amount of swords
and he's going to run out he said islam
mostly stolen
yeah he hasn't whipped it out in the
second
in the second half yet
yes we get a dumb stick me
let's get around
every time okay
you got this you got it and you're gonna
keep those five thousand souls i'm gonna
keep those five i'm not giving up those
five thousand souls it's only been ten
minutes since we started attempting it
again it feels like so much longer
yes
[Laughter]
my strategy there was i thought that
maybe if i insulted you it would help
try to get i guess it did
staring
oh
oh yeah did you know you can pair him
i haven't tried
i supposedly have to pair him
and then you get a real post
oh we see so i kept going around too
much that last time
that's gonna swing around [ __ ]
yeah we gotta repost like the first
first go
remember
oh yeah
where how
i don't know
maybe the axe did more poise damage oh
yeah we were using the axe that's right
we haven't gotten the sword yet
oh what the hell push the button and
everything
oh he could kill me no one didn't count
that out it's fine
no you could leave it
you can leave it
we watch every failure
[Music]
what the [ __ ] margaret i'm gonna fill
you up
oh no
we meet again market
hope you're nice and empty
oh we're never letting go
i know
[ __ ]
stuck in the animation
just staring
i hope other people find this as
compelling exactly oh yeah i think
i know long line up there morgan
nice
all my stamina
there we go
oh
there we go
that tail i feel like the tail is almost
designed so they can hit him yeah
the tail jiggles too so that it comes
off yeah
we're just not doing enough damage
directly to the tail
whoa
stop she's getting too much tension it's
probably
bad behavior
come on
i feel like i'm not thinking yeah maybe
my eyes feel real dry oh
oh
oh no yes oh gosh
okay i'll make work like big at work oh
god
oh you made me drink something
i get out of the way
it's not working
it's not working
oh no something oh
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
uh
that wasn't the one no that was gonna
happen anyway yeah it was going well but
i wasn't the one for sure
she knows
maybe she has like definitely [ __ ] that
the video game is the
obstacle
sword never give up jacob you taught me
that
yeah
when we were playing uh
divinity
yeah two two we'd be dying or we'd be
doing portland it'd be like you want to
reset
jimmy go no let's let's let it play out
we'd make a comeback and it'd be [ __ ]
awesome
those games are great yeah yeah i never
played the first one
yeah the first one
uh it's it's good the story is good but
the the combat mechanics and stuff
yeah
i'm getting good at dodging that if i
don't get hit by the first attack
it's a good name
people jangle all the time
good wolves
oh they're [ __ ] dead oh god yeah they
get annihilated
they're good at fighting his ankles i
guess i'm so excited to see the other
summons
there i got my hitsuit
oh you know what
uh would probably get you clicks or
whatever
they found a location
in the network test where pogba was but
he wasn't there in the network test
finding where that location is and
finding boy
and then just
uploading whatever whatever that is
from pop boy get those clicks
yes it would
everyone wants catboy
they made a little robot for their game
awards amazing
i'm sorry that's okay
it's all right hey that one's what
yeah
okay that one started bad
only could have ended bad
yes i am a quitter
all right here we go this is the one i
respect spamming next during the loading
screen
i will
oh
come on come on
come on do something
i like that one it looks cool
it's like a i feel like a ninja that was
sure
by absolutely way i saw a video where
because i guess shuriken means
like hidden in hand or something it's
it's not just the little diamond ones
it's anything
that's
concealed so if you don't see it and
closed in the ground
and
the fan
it was like these little rods these
little sharp pointy rods
she put
multiple in like the different
divots of a pan
that's awesome
y'all shout out
is it true
sure
s-h-u-r-i-k posse
uh
no i know the name for sure
it started as a mobile game right
no it was the game
the senior questions yeah
um
oh
no yeah i know her
lucy wallace
dude when i was since like college i you
know wanted to make a video before
um
but i would
i went to the library and i
check out books of like history of
weapons and everything and everyone's
books on the history of weapons
there's some craziness
yeah
oh there he goes
yeah i guess a lot of games are the same
stuff
that could have been worse oh
i wish more games had guitars guitars
are so [ __ ] cool
those always always go assassin and
ragnarok online when i was in sixth
grade
we're kind of at the same spot we
usually go
only there was an attack that did like 5
000
yeah
you should figure that out
yeah part of my plan
go super saiyan
that's always cool
i still like him i do like him he's the
son of a [ __ ] but i like him a lot
yeah
i wonder if they're gonna be any shitty
bosses
chaos remember bed of chaos john
remember me fighting bed of chaos i do
and just falling into holes
constantly
that's probably one of my favorite clips
from that uh
uh souls boy was being you do that big
monologue yeah like how about the bed of
chaos
and then i it sweeps me into a hole
he's definitely got more
he's destroying everything
here we go
sometimes it jumps away all fast
sometimes it's two swings sometimes it's
one
i don't want to gamble
just out of reach that stupid [ __ ]
tail
nope
nope
i got my back in small right now
started running a little bit
[Music]
where you going
i got one swing left in me
there we go a little tickle
oh
[Music]
oh no oh
oh that last swing i was you i was
hesitating i know because you took a
[ __ ] wrestling i was like oh oh oh
yeah
oh my god i've died that way many times
one more hit i did die like that many
times already when i was that close oh
my gosh we did it
thank you guys so much for joining me
this was fun what five and a half hours
of course
that won't be the one the longest
session development ring i
i play keep this safe and we could see
if we could somehow pick it back up
somehow i don't know how that would work
i mean i think you two can i gotta go
home i gotta go yeah
that's true that's true oh grace
oh touch the grass could you imagine
trying to play this with parsec
oh the delay
yeah we'll stream it to john yeah john
will play oh god oh we should level up
look at all of our rooms and souls
you want any bigger maybe get to 30.
okay
how about well let's just go all the way
right see how many levels we can get
29 seven
okay
here's what i'm gonna say
25
and then
some health maybe some endurance
we're pretty good on endurance i feel
like we haven't had any endurance issues
yeah
maybe one more vigor and then one more
string yeah look at that math adds up
grundle did you get like soul of
we got like a bag we got a bag from that
son of a [ __ ]
what is it let's read the lore real
quick yeah
okay oops
uh
inventory
it's either well it might be down at the
bottom if it's something you can use or
it's in key items no i don't recognize
these
key items here we go
talisman pouch wait wait is that that's
not what we got
i think i don't know what we got
it was a bag
go back to it and see if the lore
as the voices of the two fingers finger
readers are said to live lives eternal i
don't think that's not
it can't be something specific to one
class keep bumping over pump it over
oh this over here
i think it was the bag let's stop it and
check yeah
bye everyone thanks everybody